Blair scored 144 points
this football season.
He scored all his points
with 50-yard field goal--
that's actually
pretty impressive.
50.
That's close to record breaking.
Even in the National
Football League,
I think the record is like
60 yards or something.
So Blair seems like a fairly
impressive individual.
He scored all his points with
50-yard field goal kicks.
I'm just underlining
that, because I'm
impressed by how far
those field goals are,
which are each worth 3 points.
So a field goal in
American football,
I should clarify
for those of you
from other countries who think
we're talking about soccer,
a field goal is
worth 3 points each.
He played in 16
games this season.
How many field goals did
Blair make in each game?
Assume he made the same
number in each game.
So this guy is an incredibly
consistent field goal kicker.
He makes 50-yard field goals.
He makes the same in every game.
So let's think about
how many field goals did
he make in each game.
So there's a couple of
ways you can do this.
We could first figure
out, well, how many
field goals did he
make in the season?
So he scored 144 points total.
And if we divide that by 3,
we divide that by the fact
that a field goal gets you
3 points per field goal.
So the total number
of points divided
by the points per
field goal, this
should give us the total
number of field goals he had.
So this right over here is
going to be equal to-- so 3
goes into 144.
Let me do this on the
side right over here.
3 goes into 144.
3 doesn't go into 1.
It goes into 14 four times.
4 times 3 is 12.
Subtract 14 minus 12
is 2, bring down a 4.
3 goes into 24 perfectly.
It goes exactly 8 times.
8 times 3 is 24.
We have no remainder.
So 144 divided by
3 is equal to 48.
So all season, he has
kicked 48 field goals.
Now, we still haven't
answered the other question.
How many did he
make in each game?
And we're assuming it's the
same number in each game.
So this is the total
number across 16 games.
To find out the average
he makes in each game,
we divide this by 16.
So let's take 48 total field
goals divided by 16 games
is going to be-- well,
48 divided by 16 is 3.
This is equal to 3
field goals per game.
And we're done.
How many field goals did
he make in each game?
He scored 3.